there's some more there's some new cuomo
stuff coming out
and guess what it's not about the broads
you know what it's about it's actually
about covet
somebody from his administration is a
become a whistleblower and did a little
interview
now to our exclusive reporting on new
york governor andrew cuomo
and his deadly nursing home scandal we
are hearing a
new side to his decision to force
nursing homes to accept patients
infected with coronavirus for the first
time a nursing home administrator is
speaking on camera
about the governor's controversial order
that covid patients be put in long-term
care facilities who's this mafioso
[ __ ] more guy that's rolling the body
out what's that about
he really and he's got the purple gloves
too is this 1991 undertaker
apparently facilities rather than in
hospitals so what's up with her eyes
every time i can't stop looking at her
eyes just chunk from
goony's eyes chahasni spoke with that
administrator
here we go my position well okay
come on what is this now
it's like if the company that made the
cool glasses for the matrix is now
making
a mask for covid it's a little thing
that's just clipped on his nose and
covers his nose in his mouth like it's
not a full face shield
it's just covering his nose in his mouth
that thing serves
one purpose to make you look foolish
i i don't understand i'm a [ __ ] idiot
i would wear that
like as a joke right like if they were
like hey we're doing an interview about
covet are you willing to i'd be like
yo you got ziploc bags and a rubber band
i'll do an interview can you give me
like two minutes and i would just come
back with a little strip and go
i know and from
the get-go was we can't do it michael
krauss is the administrator of silver
lake specialized
care center looks great looks haunted
nile in new york and for the first time
he and his team
are telling us what
weird hat he has on really happened
behind closed doors when governor andrew
cuomo
issued that controversial march 25th if
i didn't make this
small then the hat would look even
smaller got it the hat's got to be
bigger i got to balance it out
it required all nursing homes to take in
covet patients
released from overwhelmed hospitals he
says he first heard about it how funny
would it be if this just read phil's
cuomo
hard yeah i mean don't you find it uh
you know a little suspicious
all these people coming out against me
what do they have
in common oh no think about it
what are all these people in the media
into banking pot systems they're going
like
easy easy buddy do you still want to
have a job after this bud
how do you think i was attorney general
for bill clinton
because one of his people made a phone
call
all right we've got to get this private
conference call with other
administrators
hospital leaders and state officials i
said that's ridiculous
everyone heard about the story that
happened in washington state
and you know that was enough for me to
to understand
i can't put these people at risk we
can't be doing this
she's very she's very pretty well well
you can see about the mass be
i i i don't like the masks nowadays man
because that is a very important region
it's it's just not right to the
residents and you vocalize that
on these she's pretty with the mask on
so it was [ __ ] some of the mortal
kombat chicks
okay and then they have the big barack
oh yeah exactly yeah
i did vocalize it and then you know once
it was
shot down i never spoke again there are
more important people than me
who thought it was a good idea who was
it shot down by
i couldn't tell you some of the was on a
conference call
i don't know kraus says many other
administrators
rang the alarm and then just four days
into the new order
the nation's largest association
representing long-term and post-acute
care providers
pushed out this stark warning we
strongly object to this policy directive
it reads
this action by a state will put the many
frail and older adults who reside in
nursing homes
at risk but you know what they didn't
realize this is a really important thing
andrew cuomo's dad died
so wait a minute has anybody reported on
that no one's talked about it
no one's mentioning jesus when did that
happen it's like
five years ago
it was i mean it was of old age the
group even offered recommendations to
reduce that risk
we think that the governor's members
remember when that president you all
hated sent an entire boat
and look it's hard to forget the boats
because
we milked the boats we milked the boats
for
months because it was at the time i
thought it was a very
childish stupid idea but it turns out it
was perfect
because now you had one literally there
was two boats
there's one in los angeles there's one
in new york
they had a giant ship that they sent i
think three people to
they didn't want to use the boat because
it was trump's boat
it was trump's boat and [ __ ] him [ __ ]
trump
[ __ ] white supremacy [ __ ] his white
supremacist medical boat from the navy
[ __ ] him so they didn't send like all
these time
all this time this whole fight comes
down to all right so people got covered
they sent to the hospital
then they were like yeah you're fine
they sent them back to the old age homie
after they've been around all these
infected people
and they got other people infected and
the whole argument is just non-stop
people going
well what was i supposed to do what was
he supposed to do where was he supposed
to send them
there was a giant boat all being used
two boats well i don't know was it two
in new york oh you're right one in new
york but it was
still the one in new york was empty it
was totally empty
now if cuomo had sent people to the boat
until the boat just was full
and then went i don't know what else to
do i guess start sending him back
he would almost have an argument here
for it's like i wasn't neglect i was
trying my best we were running out of
room
but like a you had the boat
b you had completely empty hospitals
with
with nurses filming tick tock videos and
posting their tits on reddit
you had entirely empty hospitals and i
know well we were afraid the hospitals
were going to get overrun but isn't that
like
don't we cross that bridge when we get
there like don't we
like if when 9 11 happened nobody was
worried about
hospitals overflowing nobody was going
to kick a firefighter out no broken back
because well we got to make room there's
more people coming in so the hospitals
were empty
keep them at the hospital for a bit they
didn't because it's too expensive
and it's like all these little angles
but it's like in any other
administration in history people would
have been like wow
the president sent that giant ship we'll
just stick the old people on there for a
couple days
until they clear a [ __ ] you know so
they do the 14 days and then put them
back
but he this all boils down to
now [ __ ] trump [ __ ] him i'm not gonna
use this stupid boat and that's why
these people are dead
oh because of the hate all because of
the hatred of orange man you're right
that's all
that's all it is state follow that
advice with the exception of new york
at the time krause feared his facility
didn't have enough ppe
he says his vendors told him they had to
prioritize
hospitals so he followed his gut and
locked down
we would take back our own patients
because that's only fair
but to take on new cases i felt was
unfair
so they were taking patients that
weren't even theirs that's good
we shut down the entire operation we had
no admissions for about 10 weeks
maybe longer i don't remember and
i mean that was my way of following the
governor's order
but refusing to take in patients from
hospitals
came with consequences many facilities
were
were threatened by hospitals to take the
covert patients
threatened in what way well i mean again
i never saw the exact
emails but they were threatened that
they um they would be reported
for non-compliance so they were strong
so it wasn't even that they would this
was this order they were strong-arming
the nursing homes to take back
covet positive people yeah and again but
for what your
your hospitals were empty yeah is it
just
are they like the teachers did they just
not want to work yeah
um they needed a whole floor to do a
nicki minaj
tick tock video mike what do you want
these nurses to do
you want where do you want to do them
and do the tick tock videos in their
home
is that what you want by the way i just
want to point out armored space force in
the chat says i don't trust this dude
fine fair enough aside from the hat he's
wearing
i would like you to explain to me what
it is you don't trust about him
what about besides his hat he's wearing
what about his story or any of his body
language or anything
makes you not trust him if you can
answer that question without describing
his hat or his nose then we'll listen to
your argument
i think in in our case we weren't
allowed
we were told please don't send us your
sick patients
there were multiple hospitals that were
threatening now we're saying don't
bother sending us your patience
wow wow in the end
silver lake reported two confirmed
coveted deaths at the facility
six out of facility and 37 presumed
covet deaths
i heard the best tinfoil hat theory
about this time sure about why they're
doing this
because you know we're getting president
kamala
before this term's over oh of course
they don't want her to have to primary
against anybody
they don't want her to have any
challengers they don't want her to have
anybody that makes her look
bad they want to get rid of anybody
that's [ __ ] got
any kind of [ __ ] even thought that's
i i don't believe that i'm just telling
that's a theory i heard from somebody
that they don't want anybody to start
undercutting kamala during her amazing
presidency that's going to be totally
scripted
and that they want to have a second term
with kamala but if there's anybody in
the democratic party
that is even remotely [ __ ] positive
sending a message
it's gonna [ __ ] undermine her the
numbers are not the lowest in the state
but
far from the highest so you following
your gut do you think that made a
difference
knowing my population i think i would i
we would have we would have had a lot
more loss of life
there has to be a better regard for the
elderly population and the
population of residents in nursing homes
that are sick they're vulnerable and i
think
they should have been given a much
higher priority
in may of 2020 governor cuomo amended
his nursing home order
now hospitalized residents must test
negative before being readmitted to a
nursing home oh okay cool i mean the
damage was done though so i mean that's
good that he amended it
damage already done did the march 25th
directive put these facilities
in an unreasonable position they were
petrified
but they were more petrified of the
department of health new york's attorney
general found
insufficient ppe and testing at nursing
homes
put residents at increased risk of harm
15 thousand people died in nursing homes
and long-term care
you know who else came out against uh
who else came out against como reese
well
sort of uh biden biden said
that not not with the nursing home stuff
but if the attorney general finds that
uh
that these women's accusations are true
that cuomo has a constitutional
obligation to step down
biden the one who was saying that he was
his best friend and there were there
were buddies and he would talk to cuomo
every single
day and i guarantee you that there were
some promises made to como too i
guarantee you that there were some
promises
yeah well you know and and biden's right
you know when you are
credibly accused of oh
for sexual misconduct during an election
you know for
for the sake of america and what's best
you know you should step down
tower read